alors jacques imaginer tu du fonds
datacell il cette immense vague de
protestations internationales
je suis bouleversée très impressionné
parce qu'on m'avait dit tout ça mais je
le découvre là d'un vrai sens de la non
j'étais quand même très coupé
l'extérieur et on m'avait préparé dans
l'avion du retour à tout ça on m'avait
montré d'ailleurs vu de presse de voir
le premier ministre le président mermaz
je dois exprimer ma gratitude à tout le
monde à vous à tous mes amis mes
confrères j'ai aussi on te prie de
m'excuser je voulais savoir si sur le
plan professionnel et humain savoir si
si tu avais tiré une leçon de ce qui
était arrivé
oui je pense que si c'est à 6 et en
faire je pense qu'il faudrait leur faire
parce que effectivement c'est un combat
jamais gagné ce combat du droit à
l'information et ce droit à
l'information est menacé comme tu le
sais mais je ne veux pas donner de
conseils je n'ai pas donné de conseils
je ne pense pas qu'il faille renoncer à
aller en afghanistan mais je crois qu'il
faudra être extrêmement prudent vraiment
et faire très attention car kelly et toi
même que la prochaine fois peut-être
le journaliste qui serait réfugié qui ne
seraient pas relâchés
les choses pourraient se passer
infiniment plus mal que pour moi merci
jacques en tout cas d'être muté
[Musique]